hey welcome to ask J it's the show that
I answer questions that you guys ask me
every single time they're always the
same you guys could please leave me some
comments below that are not the same
questions like what color is your
favorite it's crazy Kevin OT wants to
know how dead Lego Austine
is oh my
God I love my boo Bears asking if I love
my new pc and I know this is absolutely
crazy and completely out of character
for me the girl that has the eye in
front of her name I'll be posting a full
review of it but not in this video can I
draw cat whiskers on my face I can the
only thing that I have available in my
house currently is Sharpie markers so
I'm just going to do this in in
post favorite Instagram filter by far
has to be Sierra what's your favorite
Instagram filter is the question leave a
comment below favorite thing about the
iPhone 5 is how freaking fast it is guys
see wants to know if I'd rather wear
'90s clothes for the rest of my life or
dress in suits and I'm pretty sure
that's an absolute easy answer obviously
'90s cuz suits
are how is my 90day workout challenge
going here's a here's a good tweet it's
from Miley's Prince and they say that
they are Jenna who is my sister they are
Jenna's best friend and to tell her that
they say hi not to burst your bubble or
anything but I do know my sister pretty
well and I don't really think that you
are her best friend but I will tell her
that you say hello we've got a question
here asking how political I am for the
sake of all of you I do not get
political and I prefer to not share My
Views with you because I do not want to
sway your opinions either way cross your
fingers go vote and hope for the best
that my friends is political as I will
get all right I'm going to go I got a
new lens and I'm super excited about it
it's the same one that c riic and Miss
glamorazzi uses huh how does it look I
think it looks fantastic but I'm a
little biased because I'm shooting the
video don't forget to subscribe so you
guys will see when I post new videos and
I'll catch you guys later
bye